thing  yeah and it's i mean first of all you  just have to trade the bishops i think  he'll get there eventually but he's  looking for the move next move after  that and  because white's rook is so loose in the  middle of the board that's the only  reason i can suggest bringing the other  rook up  to defend it but  he's only got one minute now wei yi and  that's as we've seen that's where his  mistakes have all been in the final  under the one-minute mark  it's really turned around  unfortunately for wei yi not only is he  suffering on the position he's suffering  in terms  of his clock and there's just  unfortunately  no  proper remedy either for his troubles  and uh there we see lavones  has he resigned he has resigned wow no  hope for hawaii the tournament finishes  levon aronian is the winner of the ftx  road to miami no smile on his face so  far he will probably want to look over  this game but